marble or graphite Sarah and Dennis
mutiny are working on a design for a
mirror frame four years ago they started
the label Leal siddi based in Rotterdam
in the Netherlands its focus is interior
design having their own company together
comes with several benefits when we have
exactly the same taste and view of
things ding uh that makes it very easy
to work together we don't have to
discuss or talk about basic things
psychomotor let's go TN yeah and
decisions get made a lot faster because
we can be far more direct with each
other would otherwise plus if she can't
be reached I can decide on my own
because I know how she would decide John
wrote up the twins focus on a minimalist
designed for textiles and products among
their creations are card holders made of
stone and printed blankets they
frequently draw inspiration from age-old
techniques for instance from silk screen
yeah they keep a clear division of labor
Deena is mainly responsible for the
design while Sarah takes care of the
marketing working so closely together
has its disadvantages as well as provide
the fee it's not easy to get our private
lives mixed up with our work in the
studio done and since we're so close and
we can look over each other's shoulders
it can be very hard to keep these things
out of the studio routine specialist or
a fearless awesome shriya attack also
heightened the twins have some outside
help in the form of 22 year-old marlene
von haughton who is doing her internship
with leo siddi one of her unofficial
tasks involves helping keep the peace
around the office they are very honest
so they can tell each other everything
so if there's a problem then they say to
each other and then we despair is
something with me then we can discuss it
with each other so yeah it's very open
Sara and Dina have all their products
manufactured in Europe working together
with Dutch artists and name brands they
generally think along the same lines but
not always
sometimes tempers may clash benicia
awesome I stormed out the door and then
I thought oh no now she's sitting in
there all alone so I came back in and
she was sitting there waiting for me and
she said oh there you are again also I
knew she'd come back I know the routine
in two or three minutes the door opens
and there she is again then we had a cup
of coffee and the harmony was
reestablished the twins go looking for
inspiration in Rotterdam's artists
quarter near the main train station
Jim Deena studied in Rotterdam and had
little trouble convincing her sister of
the city's charms and merits what did i
miss your Rotterdam is young I'm
conventional always on the move it's
exciting and playful it's like a big
playground where you can try out new
things without committing to them too
much for the twins and their label
Rotterdam is a good fit it has just the
right blend of toughness and playfulness
much like the Leal studied label and the
sisters themselves